hey guys i'm tinashe and today i'm with
buzzfeed to take a trivia quiz
to see how much of a britney stan i am
first question first and foremost when
is britney's
holy birthday december 1st 1980 december
2nd 1981
december 3rd 1982 december 4th 1983.
i don't know the answer to this question
i'm already being exposed this is
question one and i'm not built for this
i'm gonna go with uh december 2nd 1981
yeah i'm gonna do it i was right i knew
it
what's britney's middle name diana jean
lynn
or brittany her first name is actually
it's of course gene
everybody knows that one boom how old
was brittany when she released
her debut single baby one more time 15
16 17 18 19
or 20. y'all i'ma go with 16. i was
correct
baby one more time was released as her
debut single on october 23rd 1998 when
she was only 16 years old and you guys
know why i know the answer to this
question
because when i was young i wanted to be
britney's fear so bad i was like
when i'm 16 that's when i'm gonna drop
my debut single
so when that didn't happen i was i felt
really bad about myself but it's okay
because i released my debut single when
i was 21
so don't rush yourself guys don't rush
life which is something britney claims
to occasionally do in her song sometimes
cry dance hide laugh sing
or order starbucks sometimes i run
sometimes i hide someone go ahead i was
right but all she really wants to do is
hold you tight which award category does
lucky win in britney song lucky
best actress best album best artist
best choreography best director or best
song
i'm gonna go with best actress i'm gonna
say she would do a curveball on this one
i actually am not 100 positive
i was right i was right which is the
correct name of britney's original
christmas song
my only wish parentheses this year santa
can you hear me
big red bow or underneath my tree easily
definitely my only wish
duh it's only my favorite christmas song
that song is a banger
which song did britney perform at the
2001 vmas with the yellow snake
toxic slay for you breathe on me hold it
against me
womanizer or stronger slay for you
it has to be boo yeah i was right which
famous writer
wrote the screenplay for britney spears
2002 debut movie crossroads oh my god i
have no idea
ava duvernay bong joon-ho jordan
peele shonda rhimes nancy myers or tina
fey
i'm gonna guess tina fey i don't know
she just seems random and
i have no idea what the answer to this
question is i'm gonna go with tina i was
wrong it was shonda rhimes
i didn't know that messed up my winning
streak i'm kind of mad
which object did the astronaut on mars
give britney in the oops music video a
red diamond ring
a heart of the ocean a purple spaceship
a bottle of stardust
i thought he gave her a picture of
herself see
this is confusing me let me try to
visualize
part of the ocean it's the heart of the
ocean oh i was right
okay how many disguises does britney
character have
in the toxic music video two three
four five six or seven i'm gonna go with
three
i was right the flighted the red-headed
badass
and the black-haired villain okay which
britney song
appears on two of her albums toxic
radar piece of me pretty girls perfume
or three radar babies gotta be radar
give me radar gaming radar give me
reader
you guys i only got one question wrong
i'm like really proud of myself
2007's blackout and 2008's
circus it's a good song so i get it but
that was always an interesting choice i
thought which artist
hasn't brittany collaborated with
tinashe
madonna rihanna nicki minaj
miley cyrus or ariana grande
has britney spears worked with rihanna
or
nicki minaj or ariana grande
i'm gonna go with rhian i got it wrong
she collabed with rihanna when did that
happen
okay okay okay you got me there that was
a good question
what can i say about collaborating with
brittany on slumber party she
is such an icon it was still one of like
the
greatest experiences ever i was fanning
out the whole time
um i got to perform it with her a few
times live at her show in vegas
and she was such a queen she was so
sweet i just loved
everything about that entire experience
i still kind of can't believe that it
really happened which of these is not
the
name of a britney concert tour the
circus starring britney spears
dream within a dream tour the onyx hotel
tour
till the world ends the tour
i haven't heard of the onyx hotel tour
but i also
can't really remember until the world
ends
let's go with the onyx hood i was wrong
i knew it
i knew it i should have done to the
world ends tour i felt like that one was
trying to trick me
and and it tricked me which of these is
not one of the things britney says
you've gotta work for
in a song a hot body a bugatti
a thick booty a party in france look hot
in a bikini
a lamborghini definitely a thick booty
we got that easy
slight work i needed the redemption
which of these sitcoms has brittany
not guest starred on will embrace how i
met your mother
sabrina the teenage witch two and a half
men i'm gonna go with two and a half men
i was correct i was actually on two and
a half men i was on a few episodes
so that's why i i've never heard of
brittany being on that show
so i had a feeling in which music video
does britney's smile get mysteriously
stretched for a split second
circus boys give me more hold it against
me
slumber party or perfume this has to be
hold it against me
boom okay hold it against me and you
won't be able to unsee it that's right
i remember that britney has five number
one hits
what are they baby one more time holds
it against me
s m remix womanizer and three
baby one more time hold it against me
oops i did it again
toxic and womanizer baby one more time
oops cited it again
piece of me womanizer till the world
ends
baby one more time oops i did it again
stronger
toxic three imma say three never went
number one i'ma cut that one out
i don't know this is so hard i'm gonna
go with baby one more time pulled it
against me
oops i didn't again toxic womanizer
i was wrong oh my god it was three
what legitimately didn't know that they
sleep it on
on toxic the gp because that's like one
of her best songs to date so
i don't know what's up with that this
just shows that you can't trust the
charts
charts equals farts finally what's the
correct
chronological order of britney's studio
album releases
baby one more time oops i did it again
britney
in the zone blackout circus femme fatale
britney jean glory maybe one more time
britney oops i did it again in the zone
blackout
circus femme fatale britney jean glory
that's wrong
baby one more time britney jean oops
cited again in the zone blackout
circus femme fatale britney glory that's
wrong baby one more time oops i did it
again
brittany in the zone circus blackout
fen patel brittany jean glory i think
that one's the one
oh my god i was wrong i was the first
one wait what i switched circus and
black
out i really thought that circus came
out first so that's
that's an honest mistake
okay i got 13 out of 18 right it says
i'm a britney stan you got that boom
boom brittany wants
because you know her inside out maybe
you're not even human because only
results like these could be so unusual
i'll take it that was so much fun thanks
buzzfeed thanks for having me
brittany i love you i got new music out
now make sure that you check out my new
single rascal and listen to my newest
album songs for you
all right you guys i love you thanks for
having me bye